lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar acerca de los procesos que hacen
que la vida sea tal como la conocemos y
esencialmente podemos llamar a esto
metabolismo
me
tap
mismo
y esto es la toma de energía en
diferentes formas y su descomposición en
sus elementos más fundamentales y luego
su reconstrucción en formas que
encontremos útiles energéticamente
útiles o estructuralmente útiles de modo
que podamos vivir nuestras vidas podamos
crecer podamos reproducir nos podamos
responder a nuestro entorno el
metabolismo y vamos a ver un montón de
ejemplos de esto el metabolismo se
compone principalmente de dos procesos
diferentes está la descomposición de las
sustancias para obtener energía o
componentes estructurales en la que
volvemos a los componentes básicos y a
esto lo llamamos catabolismo
acá está lo mismo
así que esta es la ruptura de sustancias
y una vez que hemos roto las sustancias
estamos listos para reconstruir las en
formas que no son útiles y llamamos a
esto anabolismo
anna bosch
mismo
y una manera de pensar en ello es
imaginar que alguien construye algo con
legos y tú también quieres construir
algo con legos bueno podrías ir a esos
legos deshacer la construcción y tomar
las piezas de lego individuales y luego
con eso construir la forma que quieras y
puede ser que ni siquiera tengas que
debes hacerlo hasta llegar a las piezas
básicas del ego puede haber estructuras
en ese primer castillo del ego que fue
construido que te pueden resultar útiles
así que vamos a pensar en cómo todo esto
se inicia y lo que es interesante es que
todo esto empezó en las estrellas de las
reacciones de fusión en las estrellas y
esta de aquí es una imagen de una
estrella y una estrella que no sé es muy
familiar
este es el sol y probablemente sepas que
el sol es sólo una de varias estrellas
que han participado en la vida como la
conocemos el sol es nuestra fuente más
directa de energía para la mayor parte
de la vida tal como la conocemos hay
algunas bacterias que son capaces de
vivir de los respiro
en el fondo del océano gracias al calor
que se genera ahí pero el sol es nuestra
principal fuente de energía y cuando
digo que otras estrellas podrían haber
estado involucradas incluyendo estrellas
muertas que existieron hace millones de
años es porque los elementos más pesados
de los que estamos constituidos o que
están a nuestro alrededor en el medio
ambiente el carbono el oxígeno y podría
seguir y seguir casi todo lo que no sea
hidrógeno fue creado en reacciones de
fusión a partir de hidrógeno en el
interior de las estrellas así que
realmente estamos hecho de los restos de
estrellas y aquí estamos estamos en la
tierra la tierra es toda esa materia
condensada desde hace cuatro y medio
millones de años probablemente alguna
supernova cercana junto todo este polvo
que fue creado en una estrella anterior
y se condensó de esa manera y también
está la radiación tenemos la energía del
sol y una vez más esa energía viene
las reacciones de fusión y es lo que
está funcionando a los elementos más
ligeros en elementos más pesados por lo
que el sol también está construyendo
elementos más pesados y esa energía
llega hasta la tierra hay organismos
como las plantas que son capaces de
utilizar esa energía para construir el
material o la comida podríamos decir que
finalmente va a llegar hasta nosotros y
puede que estés familiarizado con este
proceso es la fotosíntesis y vamos a
entrar en más detalle en el futuro y
como la palabra lo indica fotosíntesis
es sintetizar sustancias a partir de la
luz y una cosa que me gusta preguntar a
las personas cuando son expuestas por
primera vez al concepto de fotosíntesis
es que bueno podemos ver este pasto
creciendo o podemos ver este trigo
creciendo o podemos ver un árbol que
crece pero de dónde viene el material
que usan para crecer y la respuesta más
común es que de alguna manera viene de
la tierra y si hay algunos nutrientes
que vienen de la tierra pero en realidad
todo es acerca de la fijación del
carbono y vas a escuchar mucho sobre
esto especialmente cuando hablemos sobre
el ciclo del carbono
tenemos dióxido de carbono
principalmente en el aire así que
tenemos dióxido de carbono en el aire y
lo que la fotosíntesis permite a estas
plantas hacer es tomar el carbono en el
dióxido de carbono y formar enlaces con
el convertirlo de su forma gaseosa en
sus formas sólidas en moléculas de
glucosa y utilizar esa glucosa para
construir celulosa y la construcción de
almidón y cualquier otra cosa así que
toma estas moléculas de carbono del aire
y utiliza la energía del sol para
fijarlas para formar enlaces entre los
carbonos y con otras moléculas como
hemos dicho estamos hablando
principalmente de carbono e hidrógeno
y tenemos un poco de oxígeno también y
son capaces de formar estas estructuras
y esto se puede ir a otros organismos
vivos y lo estoy simplificando mucho
podría implicar a las bacterias y podría
implicar todo tipo de cosas y sólo como
recordatorio la fotosíntesis no es solo
la luz y el dióxido de carbono también
involucra agua así que tenemos el
dióxido de carbono co2 la luz del sol el
agua y nutrientes de la tierra y las
plantas pueden crecer y a partir de eso
puedes tomar a estas plantas que están
tomando energía del sol y construir
cosas como el pan
o puedes tener otros animales que se
comen la hierba y luego las descomponen
a su manera con la ayuda de las
bacterias y luego reconstruir las
moléculas para formar una vaca o la
leche lo que estaba que está haciendo es
metabolizar esta hierba es capaz de
descomponer la es capaz de catalizar las
diversas moléculas en la hierba y
descomponer las en sus componentes
básicos que pueden después ser
utilizados para formar a la vaca o para
formar a la leche o cualquier otra cosa
y podrías preguntarte qué son estas
moléculas que descomponemos para después
reconstruir bueno tenemos a los
carbohidratos
los carbohidratos y vas a ver a la
mayoría de las moléculas de las que
estoy a punto de hablar oa todas ellas
las vas a ver mencionadas en la parte
posterior de un empaque de algún
alimento porque te dice lo que contiene
ese alimento qué es lo que tu cuerpo va
a metabolizar cuando se come lo que hay
dentro del empaque así que los
carbohidratos son los azúcares simples
como la glucosa o la fructosa o podrían
ser polímeros de estos azúcares
polisacáridos podrían ser almidones
compuestos por muchos muchos de estos
azúcares simples podríamos estar
hablando de lípidos ácidos grasos
podríamos estar hablando de colesterol
estas son estructuras esenciales y
también son esenciales para varias rutas
metabólicas dentro de todas o casi todas
las formas de vida o podrían ser
proteínas podrían ser proteínas
compuestas de amino ácidos a veces las
personas dicen que la razón por la cual
deseamos a las proteínas es porque están
hechas de aminoácidos por lo que podrías
romper estas proteínas y obtener los
aminoácidos y luego reconstruir las en
nuevas proteínas y todas estas cosas las
proteínas y aminoácidos y todas estas
cosas se encuentran en los alimentos que
comemos que vamos a consumir y
metabolizar primero vamos a catalizar
los y descomponer los y luego vamos a
utilizar esos componentes básicos para
reconstruirlos y finalmente estos
proporcionan las estructuras que hacen
que nuestros cuerpos sean lo que son nos
permiten interactuar con nuestro entorno
y proporcionan energía
y la verdadera moneda molecular para esa
energía es una molécula llamada atp esto
es una molécula de atp justo aquí
adenosina trifosfato y la clave del atp
la razón por la que es la moneda
energética molecular son estos tres
grupos fosfato tiene estos tres grupos
fosfato y tenemos todo un vídeo acerca
de esta molécula o toda una serie de
vídeos pero la clave principal es que
hay una gran cantidad de energía
especialmente en el último grupo fosfato
y esta energía en este enlace cuando el
grupo fosfato se separa pueden liberar
la energía del enlace para
proporcionarla a todo tipo de mecanismos
importantes para la vida incluyendo la
capacidad para metabolizar las cosas así
que el atp es la moneda energética en la
vida como la conocemos y en realidad es
una molécula muy interesante porque si
viéramos solo esta sección se ve como un
trozo de arn tiene una ribosa tiene la
adenina y un grupo fosfato y esta
molécula se puede utilizar para
construir cosas como arn o incluso adn
más allá de ser la moneda energética
molecular así que es divertido ver cómo
todas estas piezas encajan entre sí y la
forma en que se pueden dividir y ves
estos patrones una y otra vez en los
sistemas biológicos y estos sistemas
biológicos son formados por la
descomposición y su reconstrucción en
carbohidratos
los ácidos grasos colesterol y proteínas
o aminoácidos
así que mira a tu alrededor observa tu
día a día y mira las cosas que estás
consumiendo y verás este patrón una y
otra y otra vez y todo es muy
interesante porque al final del día la
energía proviene de las reacciones de
fusión en las estrellas y todos los
elementos pesados que te rodean o
incluso los elementos no tan pesados
todo el carbono el oxígeno todos los
elementos que no son hidrógeno han sido
creados en el interior de las estrellas
que podrían haber existido hace miles de
millones de años así que espero que esto
te haga sentir un poco más conectado al
universo